thank you guys good to be here good
price I love from New York but how fast
I got up here pretty fast walk in here
so yes I live in a van
thanks Riley please Hospital is really
gonna have to run Dave and mother
happy Hannukah creatures I am a bad
dancer
- David Viper's I live in a van so I
think the zoo call me full-time so if
you don't think I'm funny I'm sorry I'm
trying really hard
[Music]
no excuses give me a bell I know there's
someone in the back by again I was funny
but I'll live in you're being funny you
can read that joke in an apartment buddy
I started dating side of the pan because
ladies like shelter of Atlantic's so
even if a date goes well I have no place
to take it the date so what usually ends
up happening
we go for a drive until I can work up
the courage inside we all right 45
minutes ago
so very little time I have the ladies I
am in the beautiful creep them out a lot
it is to be a woman is like a beautiful
sunset that can yell at you there like a
balance side that is pepper spray you
can't take a picture I'm single I admit
to be my soul mate
she's a little looser is today lady was
really into yoga and Stroke sex and
looks like do you enjoy breathing or not
[Music]
I work at a sushi restaurant most of my
job is to look agent actually charged
ten bucks an hour for this privilege but
I got free unborn for this job I thought
to make easy choices every damn day I
mean as sushi is a Japanese cuisine but
I'm South Korean luckily it's an
American restaurant so we all speak
Spanish English is the language of the
customer
that's what the candle speak like a kid
minimum wage and they expect me to
dedicate my life to pay these people
food you pick for the basic package you
get my personal vision human instincts
on corruption do you want my creativity
you have to pay at least 12 bucks an
hour [ __ ] out here giving it away the
lowest price of a lady for God's sake ha
ha ha
I mean minimum wage minimum effort I saw
a truck that you can hire me for 20
bucks an hour it look like ya that truck
makes twice what I mean
I can double my salary right now about
the truck I'm Aneta capitalism is fine
if you want to do it just don't make
everyone play stupid game I like
fortnight I don't make a good way I'll
play warehouses she loses like how
Americans will say communism never works
as if we didn't spend billions of
dollars and kill billions of people to
make sure it wouldn't work pretty angst
about it not working
Tommy there's another works because
whatever people control the means of
production they're democratically like
the leaders mysteriously died the small
rebel group always finds automatic
weapons and look they're getting
themselves what is they blender yourself
what we do as Americans
I'm not a communist but I do support any
policies that Republicans considered
communism which is whatever two of our
people gathered to do something nice
very good anyways those like that thank
you very much
[Applause]